the Joe Rogan experience those are the
most confusing porn videos I've ever
seen that where guys are like laying
there at girls like you look too far
dirty [ __ ] and they fart in the face
yeah mommy give me that fart mommy and
they fart in their face oh it's so
[ __ ] it's so confusing it makes me
shut my laptop and walk around the block
that's [ __ ] great I've seen a bunch of
those you never seen one else no I've
never seen it I'm just trying to figure
out who the first guy was that had the
balls to just go like smelling a fart
and going I think this is it I think
this is my you know for some people it's
its feet you know right some people it's
farts Wow yeah that's a thing with guys
farting in the face
some people like a lot of weird [ __ ]
like I had this girl in the podcast back
in the day and actually made me sad
talking to her her name was Ciara Lynch
remember her um cuz like I was like what
like what she's selling her piss she
sells like toenail clippings dirty socks
dirty underwear all these guys and then
she humiliates these guys they want her
to humiliate them and the the worst she
treats if she's what I believe she
refers to it she's a very smart girl
very pretty too she refers to herself as
a humiliate tricks like it's like that's
her business
right she bought a [ __ ] house like
she's wealthy because of getting these
guys to buy her [ __ ] and piss yeah very
strange I think I got a new nickname for
my wife but I I met this prostitute in
Lake Tahoe she'd come to my show and she
was like you know in Nevada it's it's
all legal and so she I go what's the
weirdest client that you ever had and
she goes well I don't know if you're
ready for this but I met this guy and he
lived in Colorado and he had been in in
Nevada liked her said she said she's up
for anything
sends a jet to take her to Colorado oh
Jesus
they go to Denver to some five-star
hotel come up to the suite Presidential
Suite they come in she's like I have no
idea what this is about and he goes now
this is gonna
weird but it's not gonna hurt you
just go with it
room service shows up guys got a tray
he's got four plates of hamburger meat
uncooked just hamburger meat tips the
guy leaves and he says what I want you
to do is take this meat I'm gonna get
naked and you're gonna take handfuls of
it and shove it up my ass five pounds of
hamburger he just stood there and she
kept stuffing it up stuffing out no
erection no sex no touching her and then
back on the jet back to Nevada so he's a
wealthy guy you paid her a ton of money
oh my god
[Music]
I'm surprised but I'm not surprised like
if you said would you bet your life that
there's a guy out there that sent a
private jet to get a prostitute and take
her to a nice restaurant and then paid
her to stuff hamburger meat up his ass
if you're wrong you die yeah I go yeah
tell them write a million monkeys typing
you know I mean I'm not I'm not I'm
surprised but I'm not stunned right I'm
not like no way I don't believe that
yeah I believe it well and the the the
funny thing is like I don't get the
sense this guy is on a chatroom
talking to other guys that stuff ground
beef up their asses this is his thing
right that's a personal thing he's got
so much [ __ ] money that his mind just
goes to places and he can indulge it he
can just go yeah I'll try that what the
[ __ ] man and talk about getting diseases
oh yeah well there's just an outbreak of
is it salmonella yeah from ground beef I
think someone died yeah one person died
a few other people have been it's been
they've been recalled Hey hmm yeah you
could get Salmonella anally for sure
it's raw you gotta tell your doctor
[ __ ] a what happened well have a seat
let's start for the beginning when I was
a boy first time started getting
hard-ons I sat on a cheeseburger and he
said do you think these guys if I shove
solid food up my butt would I gain any
nutrition from it first of all here's
the thing he's answered by andrew lee
doctor of acupuncture hey [ __ ] you
didn't go to medical school stop calling
yourself a doctor doctor of acupuncture
is so weird it's like I'm a doctor of
comedy yeah you know what I mean
alright you practice acupuncture you're
not a doctor they don't go to medical
school did you know that I didn't know
that doctors are doctors a doctor goes
to a medical school it's hard you have
to study you have to do your residency
you have to get your [ __ ] degree at a
medical school not chiropractors they
call themselves doctors yeah but they
don't go to medical school at all right
at all and they can [ __ ] you up they do
this on your neck pull that up so we
could read that so answer is things can
be absorbed through the membrane through
membrane what see this is help separate
routes showing you that's people have
asked this no I'm saying but listen the
way he writes the answer this is how a
chiropractor writes it versus a real
doctor things that can be absorbed
through membrane will bypass the liver
when taken through the anus through
membrane will bypass the liver through a
membrane okay for example various drugs
can be taken as through the anus in
order to be easier on the liver this is
how chiropractors right yeah CCI is
writing there's not a guy went to
medical school now as the liver no
longer needs to filter the drug which
makes the drug half as potent and is
also hard on the liver
this guy's asian how do you know that
what's his name Andrew Lee yeah I did
not know his name when I said he's Asian
I could tell by the way he was right
alcohol can cross the cell membrane and
thus absorbs very easily into the human
body
[Applause]